[MUSIC PLAYING]
OkHi is a start-up in Nairobi.
And our mission is to
give a physical address
to the 4 billion people in
the world who don't have one.
The problem is so
global and if there's
any two words that people know
in any language in the world,
it's OK and hi.
So, put them together, OkHi.
No one had it-- OkHi.com--
no one was searching for it.
There was no SEO.
So OkHi it was.
There's two developers--
one front end developer,
one back end
engineer-- a designer,
a sort of all around
hustler or he's kind
of like our lean process guru.
He's the guy that runs the
processes day in, day out,
of running these hypothesis
prints that we use.
And we have a user
experience researcher
who spends, along with the
designer, a lot of time
out of the building trying to
understand what are the use
cases, are the products
or prototypes that we
built working, if not, why not?
It's just inspiring.
There's such big problems
that technology can solve,
and that technology is
about to be able to solve.
For the first time,
with ubiquitous data
and cheap smartphones and access
to internet, for a business
or for an organization
to solve these problems,
they can do that
in a scalable way
that I don't think has
ever been possible before.
And so it's just very inspiring
to see other start-ups
and businesses solving
these problems.
And I think for me,
personally, I've
got a much bigger chance to
solve a bigger problem here
than if I was doing something
in London or San Francisco.